from Star Search to The Ellen Degeneres
Show Stephen which boss was a rare
talent and outgoing presence on
television for nearly two decades
despite lots of stories about our twitch
got his name claiming it was because he
never sat still as a kid boss himself
told al.com in 2013 that he gave himself
the name after a car he owned that would
accelerate on his own sometimes
according to him he would come up with a
loss of his choreography while he was on
the road to different performances and
teaching dance around the state of
Alabama where he grew up boss told the
outlet I was about 20 years old when I
first started dancing going places and
teaching dance
before galarenga coveted spots on the
star making shows So You Think You Can
Dance Stephen twitch boss competed in
and nearly won two other dance-related
Talent competitions early in his dance
career twitch competed on the ubiquitous
celebrity magnet talent show star search
rebooted from the original Ed McMahon
Juggernaut in 2003 Star Search came back
on the air to CBS with host arsenia Hall
it only lasted a year but in that time
twitch not only made its own but he was
also the runner-up also in 2003 twitch
competed on MTV's The Wade Robson
project where dancers would battle
against each other for a grand prize of
one hundred thousand dollars making it
to the semi-finals boss clearly remained
a fan of the legendary dancer and
choreographer as he performed at least
two solos to robson's music during his
time on So You Think You Can Dance in
that same interview boss revealed that
if he hadn't made it onto So You Think
You Can Dance he would have joined the
Navy saying everything I'm experiencing
now is because of the show
it's not easy to get on So You Think You
Can Dance first there are auditions in
cities around the country for anyone and
everyone who thinks they can dance a
panel of Judges generally made up of
executive producer Nigel Lithgow and a
selection of acclaimed industry
professionals oversee the process they
either give the contestant to pass
straight on to the next round in Las
Vegas or they ask performers to come
back later that day for some structured
choreography for a Second Chance Las
Vegas week is grueling as everyday
dancers are charged with learning a
routine from a star choreographer in a
different genre of dance from hip-hop to
Jazz to Ballroom to contemporary only
those who pass that entire week will be
up for consideration to compete on the
live shows boss auditioned in season 3
but didn't make the cut he was
undeterred however and in season four he
came back and not only made it to the
top 20 but was still standing in the
finale finishing second to Joshua Allen
since then he returned to So You Think
You Can Dance multiple times performing
as a special guest or All-Star and was
part of dozens of Unforgettable routines
one of which even caught the eye of a
certain Ellen DeGeneres leading to a new
opportunity
in 2010 Fox aired season 7 of the
popular dance competition So You Think
You Can Dance the seventh season was the
first to feature All-Stars in which
popular contestants from previous
Seasons would pair with the new dancers
competing for the current title it was
here the boss a contestant and runner-up
from season 4 met Alison holker a
standout Talent from season two Alison
was instantly attracted to Stephen as
she insisted on calling him and made the
first move as she told Jennifer Hudson
on the latter's daytime talk show you
know I would was out there making all
these moves and it took him a second to
see them but once he did you know we
locked it and we locked it in Boss
eventually lugged it down though and the
couple married in 2013. since then the
fairy tale marriage has been followed by
millions of fans on tick tock on
Instagram has produced two children and
even got them a hosting gig on Disney's
fairy tale weddings showcasing Mega
Disney fans getting married at one of
the Resort's many properties upon
announcing her husband's death Hawker
promised I Will Always Save the Last
Dance For You
before his revealing role in Magic Mike
XXL is a male exotic dancer in a ladies
Club Stephen twitch boss ranked up
several dance credits in films over the
years it all started in 2006 when he had
a small uncredited role as flamboyant
dancer in Blades of Glory following that
a twitch appeared as one of Mama Mabel's
dancers in the Adam shankman musical
reboot of hairspray rounding out his
resume was Stomp the Yard 2 homecoming
and installments 3 4 and 5 of the Step
Up franchise twitch built a steady
career out of and about dance even in
his cameo role on the TV series Bones he
appeared as a street performer dancing
for the passerby and hoping for a few
bucks in his profit hat
Stephen boss was a man meant to dance
and when he met Alison holker they
seemed to speak in the language of dance
or their own he proposed to her through
dance they announced their first
pregnancy together through dance they
performed together on Dancing With the
Stars when Alison worked there as one of
the pros they celebrated Alison's ninth
month of pregnancy with their second
baby via a motivating dance and they
warmed the hearts of followers with
family and friend dancers on Tick Tock
it's not often that a celebrity can
reach so many people and resonate so
strongly with their best dreams and
hopes for the world but Steven twitch
boss was one of those men he will be
missed in every community that treasured
his unique combination of dance laughter
and warmth
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention Lifeline by
dialing 988 or by calling
1-800-273-talk 8255
[Music]